[Musique]
la france durci le ton contre le
couronnais virus les tests de dépistage
seront obligatoires ro des voyageurs
venant des seize pays à risque dont les
états unis
ces camps turcs 1 2 tu regardes
l'épidémie dans l'hexagone plus de mille
nouveaux cas recensés et 10 nouveaux
foyers de contamination répertoriés
[Musique]
protégé des américains nouvelle devise
de donald trump et un changement de cap
radical pour le chef de l'état
concernant le produit 19 après avoir
minimisé l'ampleur de la crise
le locataire de la maison blanche
appelle désormais les américains à
porter un masque et on annonce également
à la convention républicaine prévu en
floride la barre des 4 millions a été
franchie
outre atlantique symbole fort pour
erdogan le président turc était ce matin
à sainte sophie entouré de plusieurs
milliers de fidèles musulmans pour les
prières du vendredi
une première depuis que le chef de
l'état a rétabli son statut de mosquées
il y a deux semaines après 86 ans de
neutralité religieuse pour ses textes
basilique byzantine existants
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle demi heure
d'information hausse des cas de kobe 19
en france une augmentation de 66 % au
cours des trois dernières semaines selon
santé publique france 2 109 foyers
épidémiques sont recensées sur le
territoire sept départements sont au
dessus du seuil de vigilance à la suite
du conseil de défense organisée par
emmanuel macron à l'elysée pour faire le
point sur la reprise de l'épidémie
le premier ministre s'est rendu à
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle
bassem chab y étaient sur place
c'était une visite express à l'aéroport
de roissy charles de gaulle celle de
jean castex le premier ministre
accompagné d'olivier vers en épis de
jean baptiste jebbari le ministre du
transport ils ont été accueillis ici par
monsieur hirsch le président de
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
une visite dans le cadre du contrôle de
tout ce qui a été mis en place ici à
l'aéroport pour contrôler les passagers
venant de l'étranger dans le cadre de la
lutte contre le corona virus après la
visite de l'aéroport et après l'avis
d'un stand mis en place par la rs un
stand qui permet aux passagers sur la
base du volontariat d'être dépisté ils
ont donné une conférence de presse ils
ont annoncé que des mesures allaient
être renforcées que seize pays sont
listées dans ces mesures de renforcement
le premier ministre a également
déconseillé aux français de se rendre
dans le certaines destinations notamment
la catalogne suite à la recrudescence de
cas de coronavirus je vous propose
d'écouter la déclaration du premier
ministre
nous savons que dans un certain nombre
de ces pays
il n'existe pas de stratégie de
dépistage et que donc l'acceptent est
difficile en conséquence de bois nous
avons décidé de généraliser les tests
l'arrivée et c'est ce dispositif qui est
en train de se mettre en place et je les
vues de manière satisfaisante qui va
monter en puissance pour être totalement
opérationnelle dans les prochains jours
et au plus tard le 1er août qu'avec mes
collègues ministres
je suis venu constater ce dispositif a
donc constaté penseurs va donc permettre
une séparation des flux d'une part dont
tous les pays arrivant de cp rouge
effectueront d'abord les formalités
douanières et ensuite des formalités
sanitaire consistante à faire un test
systématique les personnes dont le test
s'avère à négatif bien
aux roms la vie normale de tous nos
concitoyennes
les autres feront l'objet du dispositif
dit de 14 ans qui va permettre aux
autorités sanitaires de les isoler de
les observer et jusqu'à ce que la
situation redevienne normale
une visite aéroports alors que ce matin
le gouvernement se réunissait à matignon
mais aussi à l'elysée une cellule de
crise a été ouverte pour essayer de
lutter contre la propagation de ce
coronavirus le gouvernement craint une
deuxième vague c'est pour ça que le
premier ministre a déclaré que les
contrôles allaient être généralisé que
seize pays était est listé 16 pays qui
devront être surveillés de près et puis
bien sûr le premier ministre a déclaré
qu'il fallait éviter certaines zones
comme la catalogne
je vous rappelle que ces contrôles ne
sont toujours pas obligatoire que la
france a ouvert ses frontières de rugby
depuis plus d'un mois des contrôles qui
sont sur la base du volontariat
ici à l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle comme dans le reste du pays alors
y at il des raisons de s'alarmer comment
expliquer ce regain de contamination
éléments de réponse avec jérôme marty
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre il ya deux de réseau en
gros elle le fait qu' on a davantage de
concentration populationnelle avec des
déplacements de populations en zones
estivale une zone de villégiature on
voit bien qu'on a des endroits où vous
avez habituellement 5000 10000 habitants
qui passe d'un coup à deux cent mille
deux cent cinquante villes et on a une
période qui est favorise le un petit peu
les rapprochements on va dire et l'oubli
des mesures barrières donc ça c'est une
chose et puis ensuite on multiplie les
tests on est à 380 mille tests par
semaine on est dans la configuration du
mois de marx à peu près en nombre de
patients contaminés en augmentation sauf
que au moins deux marques sont testés
cinquante mille fois par semaine là on
est à 3 180 milles et que au mois de
mars on avait déjà des dd
malheureusement d'aider des gens qui
étaient décédées de la pathologie et ce
chiffre des décès était en augmentation
alors que là on voit il stagne donc
sonné dans une alerte qui est sérieuse
dont il faut tenir compte avec une
augmentation chaque semaine mais on a
pas de cas graves
fort heureusement parce que les gens qui
développent des symptômes graves qui
sont à risque
se protège beaucoup plus les gens âgés
ont parfaitement compris quels étaient
les risques courus de cette pathologie
manifestation de pompiers aujourd'hui à
étampes dans l'essonne où l'un de leurs
confrères récemment été victime d'un tir
d'armes à feu lorsqu'ils étaient en
intervention à les explications de notre
reporter qui est appelé les pompiers se
sont rassemblés à étampes dans l'essonne
à la suite de l'agression d'un de leurs
collègues cela s'est passé le 14 juillet
le pompier se rendait dans le quartier
de guinette pour éteindre un feu de
véhicule
il a été visé par un tir la balle a
traversé le mollet il se trouve que ce
pompier avait déjà été victime
d'agression il ya un an il y avait eu
d'ailleurs une série d'agressions alors
à la suite d'autres rassemblements un
protocole d'intervention avait été signé
en septembre 2019
il prévoyait que les pompiers soient
accompagnés de forces de police ou
encore équipés de caméras or si l'on en
croit les syndicalistes rassembler
aujourd'hui il n'en fut rien je m'oppose
de les écouter
depuis quelques années les agressions
envers les sapeurs-pompiers ont augmenté
énormément
donc il ya une dizaine d'années c'était
du verbal là maintenant on en arrive à
des gens blessés
récemment on a tous une actualité avec
des tirs de mortiers aussi donc ça c'est
l'escaladé en fait et jusqu'à bâle à un
tir de balle et donc nous aujourd'hui on
veut
ça cesse sur tout et si dans
l'éventualité on y expose et on veut on
veut être protégé on va être protégé que
ce soit avec des moyens matériels ou
pardon avec avec les moyens de police
qui travaille avec nous pour nous
encadrer
alors nous aujourd'hui on en a bon plus
que ras-le-bol ce que le terme n'est
plus approprié aujourd'hui on veut que
ça cesse
on veut intervenir de manière sécurisée
sur nos interventions
aujourd'hui on n'est pas en mesure de
pouvoir intervenir de manière sécurisée
ça veut dire que on n'est pas
accompagnée par les forces de l'ordre et
le problème c'est que lorsqu'il ya un
feu on doit les faire une reconnaissance
même si un danger sans être accompagnés
donc aujourd'hui on veut que déjà ces
mesures là soit changé dans nos
procédures
on veut plus de sanctions et clé les
fouteurs de trouble soient sanctionnés
lourdement
parce qu'aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
rapidement ils sortent dehors ils font
deux trois mois de prison et ils
ressortent dehors et c'est la même chose
en dix ans le nombre d'agressions de
pompiers a été multiplié par dix selon à
des chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
les pompiers que l'on a rencontrés ont
évoqué à leur quotidien difficile avec
des agressions de plus en plus violente
par exemple il ya peu dans ce même
quartier un agresseur de pompiers
disposer d'une machette
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur est venu au lendemain de
l'agression rendre visite aux pompiers
des tempes
il a prévenu que désormais une plainte
serait systématiquement déposé lorsqu'un
pompier serait agressé dans le cadre
d'une intervention
on l'a entendu les violences envers les
soldats du feu sont de plus en plus
fréquente les précisions en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car bus fait un pas en avant vers son
rival américain en acceptant de payer
des taux d'intérêt plus élevés sur les
prêts accordés par l'union européenne
une possible fin de litige entre les
deux géants de l'aviation airbus et
boeing
retour en images sur un conflit qui dure
depuis maintenant 15 ans devant
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales l'organisation
mondiale du commerce est en crise elle
est entravée dans son fonctionnement
pour régler ce conflit
aujourd'hui airbus fait un geste de
bonne volonté et il n'est pas sûr que ça
suffise
ce geste de bonne volonté comme vous
venez de le dire c'est qu'il accepte de
se mettre en conformité avec les règles
de l'organisation mondiale du commerce
pour ce qui est des subventions en
l'occurrence des taux d'intérêt
particulièrement bas dont il avait
bénéficié pour les avances remboursables
qui était donnée notamment par la france
et l'espagne
donc il s'est mit il se met en
conformité sur ce plan là mais comme
vous l'avez également dit il y as depuis
le mois d'octobre dernier une décision
de l'organisation mondiale du commerce
qui autorise les états unis à taxer à
hauteur de 7 5 milliards de dollars des
importations en provenance des pays qui
sont dans le capital d'airbus pour
compenser les avantages indus dont
aurait bénéficié suivant cette cette
décision airbus
on a attendu avec impatience la décision
symétrique
concernant boeing puisque boeing a
touché au moins autant de subventions
sinon plus et cette décision n'arrive
pas en effet l'organisation mondiale du
commerce est en crise le directeur
général monsieur et vdo à démissionner
il a quitté son poste hier et
aujourd'hui il ya une compétition entre
divers candidats
certains sont européens d'autres pas et
c'est un enjeu considérable puisque les
états unis bloquent depuis plusieurs
années maintenant les nominations de
juges à l'organisation de règlement des
différends et donc ils vont actuellement
quatre juges ce qui fait que l'om sait
est entravée dans son fonctionnement
aux etats unis volte-face pour donald
trump concernant la pandémie et de
coronavirus il appelle les américains à
porter un masque
dans la foulée il a décidé d'annuler la
convention républicaine qui devait se
tenir le mois prochain en floride avec 4
millions de cas de contamination le pays
est durement touchée hier plus de
soixante seize mille nouveaux cas ont
été enregistrés en une journée
j'ai regardé mon équipe et j'ai dit ce
n'est pas le bon moment pour cet
événement ce n'est simplement pas le bon
moment vu ce qui s'est passé récemment
la flambée en floride c'était pas le
moment d'avoir une grande convention
d'après moi je dois protéger le peuple
américain
il faut mais nous allons faire d'autres
choses des meetings télévisés et en
ligne pendant la semaine dont nous
parlons ce qui sera très bien je pense
que nous allons faire ça bien et je
ferai quand même un discours de
conventions sous une forme différente et
nous n'aurons pas de grosses convention
bondée à proprement parler ce n'est
simplement pas le bon moment pour sa
chaîne prochaine chine à taishan sud est
donald trump qui renoue avec un de ses
thèmes de campagne le maintien de
l'ordre
il envisage d'envoyer des agents
fédéraux dans plusieurs grandes villes
démocrate où se déroule à des
manifestations anti raciste c'est depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est déjà le cas à
portland au nord-ouest des etats-unis la
présence de la police fédérale attise
les tensions
elle a fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
hier à des manifestants à dénonce des
arrestations arbitraires les démocrates
eux pointent un abus de pouvoir
c'est très très important
l'utilisation de truffes des sceaux sous
le couvert de la loi et de l'ordre est
une technique il est en aucune façon
appropriée à notre pays et pour eric van
membres des républiques and in france
les violences pendant les manifestations
pourraient relever d'une stratégie
démocrates contre donald trump écouter
tout le monde était d'accord avec pour
protester contre la mort une humaine de
georgetown
quant au début tout le monde était toute
la nation étaient unis dans ce don pour
faire des manifestations
mais depuis ce sont
les émeutes et des pillages ce qui est
marrant c'est de voir le le maire de
tels louis aubert qui fait qui dit ça il
n'y a pas besoin d'être rien on n'a pas
besoin c'est de venir ici les fédéraux
n'ont qu'à rester chez eux alors que la
ville est en flammes
il faut se demander si c'est pas le
contraire si c'est pas la stratégie des
démocrates
autant et autant par rapport à au virus
coronavirus lui riches chinois comme on
dit ça rattrape que par rapport à aa aux
manifestations qui sont deux nuits d
émeutes faut se demander si c'est pas
créer le chaos pour détruire les chances
de trump de l'espoir de détruire les
espoirs de trump en novembre les
etats-unis qui sont toujours en conflit
avec pékin et qui viennent de décider de
fermer le consulat américain à de chen
zhu grande ville du sud ouest de la
chine
une mesure prise en représailles à la
décision de washington il ya trois jours
de fermer le consulat de chine à houston
au texas
hier le chef de la diplomatie américaine
a accusé cette représentation
diplomatique d'être une plaque tournante
de l'espionnage et du vol de propriété
intellectuelle
il est allé jusqu'à appeler le monde
libre a triomphé face à la nouvelle
tyrannie incarnée selon lui par la chine
communiste
écoutez le l'amérique ne peut plus
ignorer les différences politiques et
idéologiques fondamentale entre nos pays
tout comme le parti communiste chinois
ne les a jamais ignorer si le monde
libre ne change pas la chine communiste
c'est la chine communiste qui nous
changera certainement le président trump
a été clair nous avons besoin d'une
stratégie qui protège l'économie
américaine et notre style de vie
le monde libre doit triompher face à
cette nouvelle tyrannie les tensions
s'accroissent entre les etats-unis et la
chine c'est le regard du géopolitologue
françois costantini le combat économique
se déplacer sur le terrain politique là
où les populistes en effet
privilégiez puisqu'ils ont une avance en
termes démocratie en terme d'image et
que dans tous les cas de conflits savent
très bien utiliser l'outil larmes
l'armée des droits de l'homme les
peut-être ce sont des filles aux
mutuelles qui sont envoyées qui doivent
s'arrêter là qui doivent se poursuivre
mais de poursuivre si je viens pas mon
sens forcément sur le terrain politique
mais sur le terrain économique on pense
notamment à la gouaille la singer ont
fait que donald trump est bloqué
l'accession par exemple de google sur
les téléphones why why
donc on peut penser qu'en effet la
question se déplacera et que le dossier
de hong kong pourrait en effet être à
nouveau réouvert et se réchauffer la
russie accusé par les etats-unis de
tester une arme qui pourrait être
utilisé pour détruire des satellites
dans l'espace une propagande selon
moscou qui dément ces allégations
on voit ça avait quand un client le
commandement spatial américain a déclaré
avoir la preuve que moscou avait
effectué un test non destructif d'une
arme anti satellite depuis l'espace le
15 juillet en faisant passer un objet de
l'un de ses satellites vers un autre en
réponse la diplomatie russe a qualifié
de propagande les accusations
américaines qui ont aussi été reprise
par les britanniques
nous considérons cette nouvelle attaque
anti russe comme faisant partie d'une
campagne d'information ciblée lancée par
washington pour discréditer les
activités spatiales russes et nos
initiatives pacifiques visant à prévenir
une course aux armements dans l'espace
une fois de plus les représentants
américains et britanniques tentent de
présenter la situation de manière
déformée afin de détourner l'attention
de la communauté internationale
des menaces réelles dans l'espace le
porte parole du kremlin avait un peu
plus tôt rejeté ces accusations en
soulignant que la russie a toujours été
et reste un pays fidèle à l'objectif de
démilitarisation complète de l'espace
ces accusations interviennent dans le
contexte de discussions en cours visant
à remplacer le traité bilatéral new
start qui ont réduire le nombre d'armes
stratégique des deux pays signé en 2010
l'accord new start expire en février
il reste à ce jour le dernier grand
texte de limitation des armements en
vigueur entre moscou et washington
après le retrait d
etats-unis du traité sur les forces
nucléaires à portée intermédiaire en
cela faisait 86 ans que ce n'était pas
arrivé en turquie première prière
musulmane ce matin dans l'ex basilique
sainte-sophie en présence du président r
doan et milliers de musulmans se sont
rassemblés autour et à l'intérieur de
l'édifice emblématique d'istanbul
il est officiellement redevenu une
mosquée à la demande du président turc
une transformation en lieu de culte
musulman plus que controversée pour une
partie de la communauté internationale
on voit ça avec mes disques et fille et
serial benavides rugby une église
devenue musée puis transformée pour la
deuxième fois en mosquée c'est
l'histoire de la basilique sainte sophie
à istanbul une métamorphose qui divise
les communautés turques
construite au ive siècle cette basilique
chrétienne est d'abord transformé en
mosquée en 1453 lors de la chute de
constantinople
elle devient 500 années plus tard un
musée et perd son statut de lieu de
culte une place des plus touristiques
dans le pays
en 2018 pas moins de deux millions huit
cent mille visiteurs s'y étaient rendus
faisant de ce lieu le deuxième musée le
plus visité de turquie sous l'impulsion
du président turc recep tayyip erdogan
la tendance évolue le président souhaite
à nouveau convertir la basilique en
mosquée une volonté controversé mais qui
parvient à prendre forme le 10 juillet
dernier
comme dans toutes mosquées les portes de
sainte-sophie resteront toujours
ouvertes à tous turcs et étrangers
musulmans et non musulmans
face à ce changement de cap la
communauté internationale réagit des
manifestations sont organisées par des
chrétiens en israël la france la grèce
et les états unis avaient déjà mis en
garde
ankara sur ce sujet en russie certains
politiques par le même de provocation si
cela se produit ce sera une provocation
en revanche si les autorités turques que
l'ess sainte-sophie sous son statut
actuel
ce sera une marque de respect à la
culture mondiale en respectant le
christianisme et l'orthodoxie et ce sera
sans aucun doute un signe de respect
pour notre pays qui agit entre autres
comme le principal partenaire commercial
de la turquie
de son côté l'unesco appelle au dialogue
mais regrettent déjà la décision prise
par l'exécutif turc sainte sophie est
une composante des zones historiques
d'istanbul inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
son statut de musée reflète
l'universalité de son héritage est en
fait un puissant symbole de dialogue
première basilique de l'histoire
chrétienne construite sous l'empiré
romain sainte sophie à multiplier les
statuts et n'a cessé de faire parler
d'elle
pour faruk bilici historien de la
turquie contemporaine la décision du
président turc n'est pas une réponse au
manque de lieux de culte musulmans d'un
pays il est évident que la
transformation de la sainte sophie
mosquée ne correspond absolument rien
aucun besoin a fait d'aller dire de de
la nécessité en fait de deux lieux de
culte acceptable puisque autour de 100
sur pied il ya de très nombreuses
mosquées d'ailleurs la population
jaillir de démocrates et de gauche ont
bien souligner en fait c'est la présence
enfin de très grand nombre de mosquées
le président lui même lorsqu'il était à
farouchement opposés à la transformation
de ce monument en mosquée lui même il
est dit on peut le retrouver en direct
d'entre eux train de nous avons une
occasion pour dire que personne ne
pourrait me dire que la transformation
de la salle se fier à mosquée correspond
à une nécessité
en israël les manifestations anti
netanyahu se poursuivre
la nuit dernière des milliers de
protestataires se sont rassemblés devant
le domicile du premier ministre
repoussés à l'aide de canons à eau
plusieurs personnes ont été arrêtées
les manifestants réclament la démission
de binyamin netanyahou en plein procès
pour corruption
ils lui reprochent également la mauvaise
gestion de l'épidémie de couronnes allié
russe dans le pays
les nouvelles manifestations sont
attendues ce week je pense que nous
sommes actuellement dans une mauvaise
passe
je pense que notre gouvernement prend de
mauvaises décisions
il s'est égaré oublie de s'occuper de sa
population
c'est pour ça que je suis ici j'ai fait
deux heures de route pour venir ici
je pense qu'il est temps que netanyahou
se retire et libère la place pour que
son parti qui est aussi le mien soit
débarrassée de tous ces gens inutiles et
insignifiant qui prennent les décisions
aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ne s'occupe pas des gens
ils en font une affaire de politique et
ils disent que nous sommes violent que
ces manifestations sont violentes
mais bon nous avons été très longue de
langue comme vous avez pu le voir si
vous avez observé cette manifestation
les gens souffrent du manque d'argent et
du manque de nourriture ils ne peuvent
pas nourrir leurs enfants
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité elle dans un peu
plus de trente minutes
en attendant restez avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
levitt a été le révélateur les monstres
aux pieds d'argile que nous sommes la
france et je l'éteins elle veut devenir
veut partout mais n'a pas les moyens ma
critique les dames c'est que notre
continuant à nier l'évidence c'est à
dire le continent à mentir sur la
réalité de notre pouvoir qui est devenu
comme théâtre dans est-ce que cette
france là vous fait moins peur que celle
que vous avez décrite